hi everyone I'm Jackie and I'm here to
show you
electroporation using the neon
transaction system specifically I will
be transecting induced pluripotent stem
cells or CRISPR calf 9 genome editing so
before you begin you want to make sure
that your cells are looking healthy and
you want them at around 70 to 90 percent
confluency in your culture dish so I
have a 6-well plate containing my IPS CS
I'll show you on the microscope about
what they should look like you can see
that they're about 70 percent conflict
or around there and the cells look good
so we're good to transect so to prepare
yourselves the first step is to
dissociate your cells from the culture
dish to do this you want to first
aspirate the media from the south
[Applause]
next you want to rinse yourselves with
PBS without calcium or magnesium
[Applause]
you can rock your plate back and forth a
little bit to make sure that this all
the cells are rinsed and then you can
operate the PBS
[Applause]
so now you want to add your dissociation
reagent in this case I'm going to be
using Tripoli express this is a really
good enzyme used for dissociating a wide
variety of adherent mammalian mammalian
cell types with minimal damage to
yourself for a 612 plate you can add
about one millimeter into the dish
[Applause]
now once your Tripoli Express is on you
want to put your plate into an incubator
at 37 degrees Celsius for about three to
five minutes and this should allow
yourself to lift off of the plate
[Applause]
so while the cells are dissociating I'll
go ahead and tell you a little bit about
the neon transection system itself so
there are three main pieces to the
device one is the neon device which is
this silver benchtop piece right here it
has are really easy to use interface
which is really nice and it has a
touchscreen it also comes pre-programmed
with 24 well optimization protocol if
you're looking to determine which
protocol is best for your cell type
there is an online neon cell database
and it has recommendations for the
protocols for most common cell types so
I would check that out if you don't know
which one to use the second piece is the
neon pipette station and this holds the
neon tubes these tubes come in the neon
kit and they have an electrode at the
bottom which actually transfers the
electric electric field from the
electrode in the neon tips
the neon tips come in 100 microliter and
10 microliters size and for the case of
the training today I'm going to be using
the 10 micro litre chips I've also
already loaded my neon tube into the
neon pipette station and I have added 3
mils of buffer II which also comes in
the neon kit into the tube the third
piece is the neon pipette and this is a
fixed volume pipe header and it's
designed specifically for the neon tips
and when you're ready trip to transfect
you load the entire pipette into the
neon pipette station for the transaction
so ourselves should be done associating
soon so you can now prepare your plate
that you will be putting the electric
rated cells into I have pre coded a 24
well plate with laminin 521 this is a
feeder free culture matrix that when
used in combination with our stem flex
media will give you really good post
electroporation cell survival stem flex
in general is really good for any
application where your IPS peas are
under stressed particularly if you're
using single cell packaging or doing
reprogramming or in our case genome
editing and then to further enhance post
electroporation cell survival I'm going
to add revita cell into my media and
revita cell is just Rock inhibitor with
additional antioxidants and this is
really good to use whenever you're
single singular izing your IPS CS it'll
give you really good post
electroporation survival
so I've already prepared the stem flex
media with revita cell and I'm just
going to add a half a mil of media per
well of my 24 well plate and you want to
prepare as many wells as you have
transfection x' to do since I'm just
demonstrating today I'm just going to
prepare one well
[Applause]
so you just want to uh spray it off the
laminin five-to-one that's already on
there
[Applause]
and then add a half a mil of your stem
flex plus provider
[Applause]
[Applause]
so now our destination plate is ready
and our cells should be dissociated
[Applause]
you can check to make sure that your
cells are starting to lift off the plate
by looking at them under the microscope
you can see that the cells have started
to round up and they look like they're
starting to lift off the plate that's a
really good sign and your cells are
ready to harvest
so to neutralize the Triple E Express
that we put on the cells you want to add
one volume of your culture media to the
amount of Triple E express that you have
in the well so I'm going to add one mill
of my stem flex plus revita style on top
of the Triple E that's in the well right
now
[Applause]
and then you can rinse your well a
couple of times to make sure all of the
cells come off of the plate
[Applause]
and then you want to collect all of your
cells in a 15 ml conical
[Applause]
so at this point with the cells that you
harvested you want to get a cell count
and then you want to spin your cells
down at 300 G's for five minutes and
then you want to aspirate off the media
and Triple E and then resuspend your
cell pellet in buffer our buffer art
comes in the neon kit as well and you
want to resuspend your cell pellet to a
density of twenty million cells per
milliliter so for the sake of time I
have already prepared my cells at 20
million cells per mil
[Applause]
you want to make sure that your cells
are singular eyes because this will be
the best for transparent and give you
the best transaction efficiency so I'm
going to just pipette my cell suspension
a few times to make sure there's still
singular eyes
[Applause]
so I have also pre-prepared a tube that
contains my guide RNA and the Cassadine
protein the guide and protein have been
pre complexing for a little over ten
minutes and you want to make sure that
they pre complex for at least 10 minutes
at room temperature before you have the
cells to it and then at this point since
it's already been pre complexing for 10
minutes i can add 10 microliters of my
cell suspension to the guide and protein
free complex
[Applause]
and now
your cells are ready for electroporation
so the first thing you want to do is
make sure that the neon pipette tip is
properly attached to the neon pipette
to do this you want to take the pipette
and depress the plunger all the way down
until the clip at the end of the pipette
is open and then you want to put a good
amount of downward force on to the neon
pipette tip and then just release the
plunger and then your tip should be
properly attached then you can take your
cells plus payload complex and just
pipette up one pipette volume try not to
get any air bubbles in there because
that could affect your transfection
and then you want to just put the entire
pipette with the tip and your cells in
it into the pipette station and make
sure you push all the way down until you
hear it click into place now if you go
over to the neon device you can select
your protocol by pressing the
optimization button and then all of the
protocols will pop up and you can select
the one that you want to run for the
sake of this training I'm going to
select option 5 and then I'm going to
press load to load the protocol you can
see that the protocol that protocol 5 is
loaded up here it displays the number 5
and then all you have to do is press the
start button and the electroporation
should take place sometimes it displays
a tip connection error in that case you
might have an air bubble or you might
need to just try pulling the pipette out
and putting it back in so let's see if I
can get this error to clear
[Applause]
nope let's try this again
[Applause]
so it looks like I do have a little bit
of an air bubble that's probably what's
giving me the air
[Applause]
all right sorry about this let's try it
again
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm still getting error about air
bubbles and the issue could be that the
tip is not properly attached to my
pipette tip or to my papa
hopefully this was a humble issue
[Applause]
nice okay it worked so once your
electrician is successful complete will
appear on the display and at this point
you can deposit yourselves into the well
that we prepared earlier
[Applause]
so that error was likely due to the tip
not being properly attached to the
pipette and then you can just use the
pipette as you would a normal
micropipette and deposit yourselves
directly into the well then you can
eject the tip by pressing all the way
down on the plunger and then you can
rock your plate back and forth a little
bit to make sure that the cells are
evenly distributed throughout the well
and then I can show you on the
microscope what the stalls will look
like immediately after electroporation
[Applause]
so you can see the cells floating around
in there this is just to give you an
idea of what it looks like
immediately after transfection you want
to put your plate directly into an
incubator at 37 degrees just to make
sure that the cells adhere to the plate
and recover nicely
[Applause]
it's recommended that you leave your
cells untouched in the incubator for
overnight or 24 hours to make sure that
they attach appropriately and recover
nicely I prepared an electroporation
yesterday so you can see what the cells
will look like about 24 hours a lot
after electroporation show I'll show you
on the microscope
[Applause]
so you do see a lot of debris but you
can also see quite a few cells have
started to attach for instance here you
can see like the live cells have started
you're attached that's a good sign your
cells will recover nicely so at this
point the final step would be to run an
assay to determine your transaction
efficiency in the case of genome genome
editing you can do a genomic cleavage
detection assay this is where you'll PCR
your targeted region and then you will
denature and Rhea Neil your PCR product
if you have genome editing this will
create mismatches and then you can
introduce a detection enzyme which will
actually cleave where the mismatches
have occurred I've prepared a slide
which shows a GCD a say after genome
editing using hprt guides you can see in
lane 1 that there's one clear bright
band and there was no guide added to
this Lane or to this electroporation so
that band is showing you your fully
intact product in lanes 2 through 5
there are two clear bands that in these
lanes guide was added at different
concentrations and the two bands
indicate that mismatches occurred during
your assay and this indicates a
successful electroporation so at this
point we've sort of wrapped up the
training on yon electroporation and if
we have some time I'd be happy to take
any questions
do we have any questions all right Thank
You Jackie this is Eric speaking and I
will be working with Jackie through some
of the questions that we have received
online so I'll try and divide them up in
different kind of categories so one is
more one group is more around the
instrument itself so could you speak a
little bit more in terms of the
difference between the 10 microliter tip
and 100 my creator tip that you
mentioned yes like I said there are 10
microliter tips and 100 minor for
microliter tip options you would select
which tip you wanted to use based on
what's recommended in the protocol that
you're using which as I mentioned you
can find on the neon cell database you
can also predict which tip you'll be
using based on the number of cells you
wish to transfer via Slee the 100
microliters tip can accommodate a much
higher number of cells than the 10
microliters it can and so follow-up
question on that was that whether you
could reuse these tips multiple times
for multiple electro creations so just
as with any pipette tip it's not
recommended that you reuse a tip because
you could cause cross-contamination but
in an instance where you might be doing
duplicate transactions or something like
that you actually can reuse a tip but
it's not recommended that you use a neon
tip more than two times in a row because
the electroporation can actually cause
thinning of the coating on the electrode
of the tip and this can mess with the
conductivity of the tip and affect your
transaction
all right Thank You Jackie would you be
able to address how the neon system
works with different cell types they
require individual buffer systems for
the cell type that you use or how does
it work the neon
kit comes with a number of buffers you
can use in this instance I use buffer R
and that's because I'm using IPS CS but
it also comes with a buffer T which you
can resuspend yourselves in but this is
for blood derived suspension cells only
so in most cell types you'll be using
buffer R and then in buffer a versus
buffer e 2 which are both supplied in
the kit buffer e is used with the 10
micro liter tips primarily and buffer e
2 is used with the 100 micro liter tips
primarily and I think there's a
difference in osmolarity between the two
and they're optimized for the 10 micro
liter tip or the 100 micro liter - all
right all right that sounds really good
because that actually sounds like you
can use 1:1 buffer for the majority of
adherent cell lines moving on bringing
the electroporation piece more into the
area of pluripotent stem cells so what
are the kind of things that you can
deliver with the neon very efficiently
so as I demonstrated here you can
deliver a CRISPR cos 9 really
efficiently you can also deliver a
number of proteins you can deliver DNA
you can deliver si RNA all with really
high efficiency and and how does that
delivery compared to for example a life
of fection reagent like life effect
amines them or life effect amine 3000 so
electroporation in general will give you
a much higher transaction efficiency
than other types of transfection such as
liposuction and particularly in
instances like genome editing you're
really concerned with getting the
highest transaction efficiency possible
so with the electroporation though are
you concerned at all about cell survival
post delivery
I mean that's always a concern with
transfection and particularly
electroporation because you're putting
the cells under a lot of stress but I
touched on this earlier laminin five to
one paired with our stem flex media and
especially for stem flex media that will
really up your cell viability post
electroporation and then if you odd
revita cell to your media that will
increase your cell viability postal
expiration even more okay
now maybe going a little bit more in the
terms of protocols for the neon are
there any specific protocols that you
could use for pluripotent stem cells or
would we have to optimize for every
single pluripotent stem cell line that
we have so most cell types are the
recommended protocols are described in
the neon cell database so it's likely
that you would be able to find your IPS
C line in the database if it's not in
there you can identify the cell type in
the database that's most similar to the
one that you're using and then you can
optimize like that's a good starting
point to do your own optimization from
there and you don't actually have to go
through the full 24 well optimization
but that is an option as well so could
you maybe elaborate a little bit more
about the 24 conditions optimization how
you would go through that yeah so like I
mentioned earlier the device comes
pre-loaded with 24 optimized protocols
which you can load onto the device and
perform your electroporation the
differences in the each protocol is a
difference in the number of jobs you're
delivering and the voltage that you're
delivering things like that and you can
go through all of them if you desire and
see which one gives you the best
transaction efficiency and best survival
for your cell type okay so you mentioned
that several tricks to promote the
survival of the cells after
electroporation could you kind of
ballpark how long it takes for the
to recover and be ready for expansion
and other experiments so if you have the
most optimized protocol for your cell
type you should start to see yourselves
adhering to the plate and looking
healthy after about 24 hours and then
your cells will grow at whatever rate
your cell type tends to grow at and then
you can expand from there okay going
back to the neon device itself is there
any difference in the efficiency between
the 10 microliters dip and the hundred
microliter tip and would there be a
reason in terms of efficiency why you
would choose one over the other so I
would definitely choose which tip to use
based on the recommended what the
recommended protocol says but there's no
reason to believe that there's a
difference in transaction efficiency
between the 10 microliter tip and the
100 microliter tip something to keep in
mind though is that you do need to scale
up your transfection so make sure that
your cell density stays the same
[Applause]
also if you do see that it's it doesn't
work as well when switching between the
two tips you can adjust the voltage
slightly and that should correct for any
differences that you see okay
and now we have another question that
came in regarding transfection
efficiency so would you be able to speak
a little bit about let's take the genome
editing as an example what kind of
efficiency is that you're getting with
genome editing after using the neon as a
delivery machine so the transaction
efficiencies the transaction efficiency
you see totally depends on what you're
delivering and your cells - and things
like that typically you can see maybe
between like twenty and forty percent
transaction efficiency but again it
totally depends and that's just a
ballpark estimate okay so in in terms of
then using using the the neon for genome
editing would you really recommend to
use the neon or do you think that life
effect means them would also work for
genome editing specifically I would
definitely recommend using the on
electroporation because like I said
earlier in genome editing you're really
concerned with getting a high
transfection efficiency and the neon
electroporation system will give you a
much higher electroporation efficiency
than something like life effective
instead all right Thank You Jackie for
your wonderful demonstration I'm sure it
wasn't informative for our audience and
I would also like to thank our audience
for their active participation in this
live session thank you very much and I
hope you enjoyed the rest of our 24
hours of stem cells event yeah thanks
for tuning in and joining me here to
learn about neon electroporation it's
been fun
[Applause]
you